lleva meses detenida en rusia por
posesión y contrabando de drogas la
estrella de la doble o en vía y brittney
griner fue llevada a una audiencia en la
corte presionando a la administración
vaivén para que trabaje por su
liberación el secretario de estado-
anthony blinken dijo que eeuu ha hecho
todo lo posible para la liberación de
greiner y del ex marine paul weller
condenado hace dos años por espionaje
joven en los próximos días espero hablar
con el ministro de relaciones exteriores
ruso lávrov por primera vez desde que
comenzó la guerra tengo previsto
plantear un tema que es de máxima
prioridad para nosotros la duración de
los estadounidenses paul huelan y
brittney griner que han sido detenidos
injustamente hace semanas pusimos sobre
la mesa una propuesta sustancial para
facilitar su liberación louis rusia dice
que las conversaciones están en curso
pero que aún no hay resultados concretos
según los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses washington está
dispuesto a intercambiar al traficante
de armas viktor bout también conocido
como el mercader de la muerte a cambio
de graner y whelan
administración no lo ha confirmado pero
sí insinuó que podría estar preparando
un canje
el presidente y su equipo están
dispuestos a tomar medidas
extraordinarias para traer a nuestra
gente a casa como hemos demostrado con
trevor grit y eso es lo que estamos
haciendo aquí para girar traver ruiz es
un veterano de la marina como well han
liberado a través de un intercambio de
prisioneros en abril